my
okay for people joining this live stream
we
are doing some things as we prepare to
release version 12.3 of orphan language
although it's still going to do a while
before it's ready for release
it's about to go into testing um and we
are looking
today at data set themes
and chris was just saying there are 58
of them to look at so that's quite a lot
all right so we need to look at the
appearances
the naming and the parameterization of
some of them
um oh gosh hold on one second guys i'm
sorry to send
sorry guys okay here we are
okay so those are the themes
and rather than go through this text you
should probably just jump to the next
section which has examples
right so you can just like open all of
that oh my gosh
well okay so select select the theme
examples bracket and just open
everything
well
okay okay so these are these
base themes uh were specified by tim
i think that's too heavy i think it's
way too heavy
is tim here by the way yes
yeah i'm here and is is um uh who here
who is here from design
uh nobody okay they need to be here so
can we get jeremy
yep i'll get jeremy
tim i think this is too heavy i think
this is too bold here
i i agree with you i think it's a little
heavier than i imagined
okay well i mean it may depend on the
font rendering on different machines
um
so i don't really understand what is you
know by the time this is
gray background it doesn't have to be
bolded and and what by the time it's
i mean i'm i'm confused here um
okay let me just get a start getting a
sense here so these are
okay but but but this is a
this is a code font right and i don't
think we were using code fonts for the
most part
for these things um
it's uh what is that i think it's
verdana i understand but that's a code
font
that is a code font right there that's a
code font that's not the default font
of the of data set you see what i'm
saying
that's not this font yeah okay yeah okay
so that's wrong
right this is a code font so you know
like our
um whatever it is our um
what is it called uh source sans
code font right
so something goofed there but let me
just get a sense of what we're looking
at
so so
what are the pieces here so i mean
there's a basic
bank switched choice which where we're
doing something different from this
right right those are the base themes
right did we find uh jeremy somebody i
did find jeremy and he is on his way i
just sent him the
meeting invite
great i mean so the first question is
what do we not
like about this classic thing the
classic thing to me
has about the right relative weight of
the labeling versus the content
you see what i'm saying whereas when we
go here
it's like boom you know we've got
labeling and the content is like oh well
yeah i guess there's numbers there but
we don't know what they are
see what i'm saying um
and and i mean tim did you intend that
to be a background color here it looks
like there's some slight background
color but it's hardly visible
oh that's white i don't i don't think
they're supposed okay and then there's
also
there's there's background color in
those total cells
okay but that's that looks wrong as well
relative to these things here
jeremy's here now okay hey jeremy we're
reviewing
dataset themes okay and i'm not very
happy so far
all right um okay we just started by
looking at the
current default okay
this is the current default
okay so let's first of all let's talk
about the names
for by the way i don't think we should
be calling it marketing going forward i
just don't think i think we should be
calling it
you know uh some other name like brash
or something
something which doesn't which is not a a
job description
you know what i'm saying the same thing
with yeah same thing with business too
yes yeah business and marketing we're
gonna change but what do you think we
should change them to
i mean you know should it be an
adjective like brash
or or you know i brought up the name for
business i thought maybe something like
bravado
or something like that yeah that wasn't
well received
no i don't think that's quite right and
marketing can be
a descriptive thing like dark neon
because throughout it's a dark
background
and then like in plots and things it's
neon color great dark neon that's nice
that says a lot more than i mean
do we have another dark mode i thought
that one seems good but it'd be nice if
we didn't
only have dark neon is the only dark
choice yeah the problem is with maps
there's a dark vector already
so we can't just call it dark yeah
i'm just saying like if neon's part of
it then maybe there's another version of
dark that isn't quite so neon
yeah well so the thing we got to get
across okay so
in the case of um of plots
right i mean we we should how did i best
do this
um
uh how do i get a list of plot themes
uh you can
there we go yeah but i want to see
doesn't dollar plot things get the time
is there a dollar plot themes
i don't know what context it's in there
is one yeah
yeah tri-dollar plot teams make sure
it's plural
boy we should be going to that for our
default
make sure it's plural plotting that's
how you said it
okay uh it's it's in the chart
it's charting exact tip yeah charting
backtech
there you go there we go okay
so what what do these sub things mean
here
they're they're groups by category like
axis that's all they access things
these contain micro themes and then see
bass themes it's like yeah i see that i
see that yeah
those are based off a lot of these other
themes
so it's broken down into a bunch of
markers so look the ones we don't like
minimal monochrome they're fine
i don't particularly like okay detailed
what does detailed really do yeah let's
take a look
it adds things like grids
and uh legends so it adds detail
it's kind of the opposite of minimal
yeah i think those two are both fine
i mean the thing i just don't like i
just don't you know when i say i want to
use the marketing theme
i just that feels wrong to me
yeah okay this was discussed in other
meetings so i mean we are changing
business and marketing okay well let's
decide what we're changing them to i
mean so that okay so that
so you're proposing
dark neon was what
i mean here's a word the word stand out
might be a possible word you're using
bold and it's along the same lines but
it
feels better like dark bold and we'd
have bold and dark bold maybe
well i think bold has the problem that
it might be bold fonts
ah yeah wait yeah but so what's a
synonym for bold
do we have a thesaurus in the wolfram
language we do
but um here let me let me um
i'm for some reason with the thesaurus
but the only thing where i have this
paper thesaurus
written by this person we know um that
i've been
using for millions of years uh
brazen audacious
vivid dark vivid vivid is nice
vivid as a nice name word
um steve on the livestream is suggesting
heavy that's an interesting word as well
that's an interesting word for maybe a
theme we don't yet have but that's a um
colorful is another possible word
for something
let's do this just brave
um
uh powerful robust
strong yeah strong is okay
daring i don't know whether that's a
um
let's see uh
flashing lively flashy
loud
okay i think okay so let's let's look at
some of these
because i mean okay so that's what
marketing looks like
and web we think is still useful as a
term right
is that really being used as on the web
or is that really being used for other
purposes
and could we have something which i mean
what does web really do
it cuts out what does it do
tim it's just a nice clean bright
look it's more of a modern look
okay this bright this clean
um
up i want to go to
visualization
okay so what would you name if if you
were
naming this um
[Music]
the question from voiceless does web use
web safe colors
what's the answer to that tim um
no i don't i mean it's well the web tape
is a
outdated term you know days
does anybody care about it at this point
i don't think so i mean that that's when
monitors were constrained 8-bit color
that was important it's it's really not
a concern anymore
um okay but so
so here what we've got we've got this
web marketing we've also got what does
what does the business theme do here
you know if you open up plot theme the
documentation it's got a
description of each one
click on details
and then there's a description of each
one okay bright modern look
detail elegant
well it's actually not that elegant it's
eye-catching though
um
all right look we have to rename these
and we probably want a few extras
as well i mean we probably want
something which is pure
dark as opposed to this you know
this bright case here
and maybe um i mean bright dark is
obviously
a very poor name
okay what is our process going to be for
getting these renamed
and and how many do we think we want to
end up with
tim are you anyone figuring this out or
who's figuring
well i'll be working uh i will be
working on it i mean
um
this is brand new maybe we should get
brett
and roger we kind of all discuss things
okay so maybe come somebody see if we
can find brett please
yeah i'll try to find brett okay all
right let's let's go back to our our
primary thing here which is
you know so to me we need some of these
words like vivid
uh lively maybe
you know um
you know we've got other words like this
um i don't know which of these words
are right but i think what we should
think about is given the word what we
want it to look like
and can we map one of these words
directly onto what we're doing for these
other things
already for these other things here that
make sense
yeah but i suspect we should end up with
two or three more
base base for base themes make sense
well there's one i was thinking about
doing anyway that would be an all black
um what's this monochrome has grayscale
see now we have all the um
different fillings like uh you know i
see and
incorporate those
so that's like black white or something
in fact that's the name i had for to
begin with yeah
well i mean if we have this set up to
just have the dark version of each of
these
i i don't right because i i end up like
i like marketing but only because in
certain cases the dark is nice but
some of the other pieces i don't love
yeah
that makes sense well hold on what do
you mean by dark for
all well so so dark web let's say
actual dark web but but bright simple
clean but on a dark background
so basically each one with just a dark
background yeah i mean why not it's it's
just one of variant
and you've got the style set already and
just make it work on a dark background
yeah but the colors will change that's
the part obviously you want to change i
mean
the dark version of each of these will
be different from the non-dark version
but maybe the hue sequence is the same
so you know you start
off with the roughly red you know
whatever the color cue sequence is maybe
stays the same
right i mean you know tim is thinking
there's lots of work to do in those and
yes there is but it's but it's important
um
yeah i think i think there's a possible
word in other word might be nice as
lightweight
there's another concept i mean what are
the concepts we're trying to get across
here you know our original thinking with
plot themes was
you know we knew some of these like you
know detailed et cetera et cetera
i mean maybe maybe there's one called
publication
or what would that would that be that's
basically scientific
okay because see we we
uh experiment with
ones that would be geared towards
specific publications
i understand that but i think we can get
a a you know publication a monochrome
publication
seemed like they would be useful
right um
but maybe publication is again too
specific i mean maybe it's too
it has the same problem as something
like marketing or business because
it's like why are you putting this up on
the screen with the word publication
it's very weird
if i'm just working on some random i
mean i don't mind using minimal
as a plot theme in just everyday work
i'm doing but it's pretty weird when i'm
using
business in everyday random research
type stuff that i'm doing
see what i'm saying yeah we have brett
now
okay we're talking about the redoing of
plot themes
okay and some renaming and some new
themes
okay um all right we're gonna loop back
to this but we are coming back to the
original topic which is
uh themes for um
data sets okay and i'm not
i'm not liking what i'm seeing so far
okay so
what again what we want to achieve here
so again if this was called if business
was called vivid for example
how do we feel about what do you think
about that
a reasonable name
i'd say it's more colorful and vivid
okay well
i mean okay but so then it would be
colorful and what we the actual one we
have right now is dark
colorful is that correct because we
have a dark prefix for everything with a
dark background
is that correct yeah colorful is
pretty generic though i mean they're all
colorful yeah
i think this has to be
you know stand out or
you know what is your what are you
achieving with well okay
i'm not i'm looking at marketing aren't
i here so
help me out what what do we think this
you know the description here
elegant eye-catching
help me out with what what you think the
tim as the designer of this stuff
what is your word to describe this i
i mean just what we put down there
i bet i need one word
dark neon that's two
okay but neon is a i mean okay so that's
just
the color that's used in it you should
try um a couple other
try like bar chart too there's some
other rendering effects that are used
that are non-standard they're more showy
that you don't see in plots
oh boy
and pie chart i mean so so this is where
you have free reign to use all sorts of
effects
that you probably wouldn't use in other
cases
you know and see the point is that tim
to some extent here
is you know he is designing to the
to the name so to speak yeah right
and these are you know suitable for
marketing presentations
it kind of suggests that we should boy
that we should try to get the same
you know some of the same functionality
i hate this term marketing it's just the
wrong stuff it might be okay for this
visualization but maybe you want some
other dark ones like you maybe wouldn't
use this you might not use this for bar
charts or pie charts
that's okay some people might but you
probably want a nice dark
theme absolutely i mean but again
this is designed to the name right
you know we're gonna do a marketing
presentation what should the pie chart
look like okay there it is
and i think we're saying the same thing
jeremy we want something which is
the same kind of colors but without the
fancy i i think so i just feel like
marketing maybe isn't bad but it's it's
not
the default dark thing any most people
would want right
it has its place but it's probably you
know right now it's the only dark theme
so it's the one you reach to when you
want something dark
right i mean so we have the you know
further down on that plot theme page we
have
the color themes
which have
those are very sensible i mean those are
very clear what what kind of thing they
are
right
sandra is suggesting insipid as a name
for something
um see the thing is
the problem here is that we don't want
value judgments in these names
they're just like you have it you could
not have it neon color
you know there's no value judgment
um right i mean
at the same time you don't want things
that are too generic yeah otherwise
nobody knows what the heck it is
yes um
see but i also feel like people will
learn this is a theme i like
it has this name just like people learn
there's a font i like it has this name
um all right well look we maybe we'll
loop back to this but we've got it we've
got to address the
the data set question okay so
again see i wish we could adjust it with
with better
named themes because this is just
horrible because i don't know what we're
going to do with this
okay first point is
oh boy okay what is the what is the
serious
uh freedom that we have here so one
thing we have is the alternation of
colors right
another thing we have is the background
color and fonts here
right so again to my mind
this is just completely losing it i
don't understand why you would want to
emphasize
the headings this much relative to the
content
yeah this one this particular example is
even more extreme because that text
since its quantity is formatted
it's not black it's a light it's a
lighter warm gray
okay fine but but um i mean so
okay so what should we do with this
first of all again
i don't think this font works at all
so what is that font is that the bold of
it of the standard thing or is that a
specially chosen font
no it's i think it's bold for dana
okay well it's okay
so what is our default font for dana
so that's just the bold of this really
yeah so if i say something like this
and i say font family arrow
kadana okay so let's check it's that
okay
and if you say i say the bold version of
that
wow that's horrifying we don't have to
stick with the verdana
that is a bull bold yeah i mean you
could easily go source
source sands and source and semi bold it
ships with the product it's always going
to work
but is sauce sounds not very cody
no sour sans pro no it's not very much
code yeah no
it put us put a space sour sans pro
i don't know what i think you bet you're
getting ariel there
oh i see and you have to space pro
capital p
yeah okay so that's a slightly smaller
font as well
yeah so for a given font size it renders
smaller
okay so then we might render everything
in source sans parallel
including all these numbers and so on
right yeah
okay and then what you're saying is the
the um the bold of that
bold is bold but you can go font weight
goes to semi bold and it's
it's in the middle
that's not bad yeah but do we even want
okay explain why these labels are bold
because i don't get it
do you understand what i'm asking to me
depends what the labels mean but i don't
see any reason why they would be bold i
mean if they're on a background color
they might or might not be the main
event relative to the the uh
the actual content here can you do it
with a data set that doesn't have
units on everything
i am i'm sure i can do titanic
well tell me what's his type okay so
just disreplace
planets with titanic
oh yeah that's classic but now let's see
what happens if i'm
looking at um like your business
version or let's say marketing
okay well that's not bad i mean that's
that
see i i just don't know do you want the
heading to stand out or do you want the
the content to stand out is it you see
what i'm asking
i think you want the heading to stand
out some at least okay this looks really
sucky
in my opinion that just doesn't make it
yeah but at the same time the classic
one
yeah where the text was the same
i don't think the classic one is that
terrible but also the other thing that's
wrong
is that this light gray down here is
definitely not making it with all this
stuff here
is that changeable chris
i can make it changeable it's not
currently
okay well i think it needs to because i
don't think that looks right guys
any comment on that
it's a very light gray from what i can
see yeah but but jeremy do you have any
comment i just don't think it works with
this
yeah if there were a line it was white
it would be okay if it fits with the
the rows of the body it probably is
better i i don't think you want to give
it a bunch of color though
no no no no no no but it just it just
got it's got to fit with the rest of the
yeah exactly yeah yeah okay
so i mean i don't think this i don't
think that looks bad
you know that all fits right we don't
have this weird floaty thing
to happening down here so what i'm
saying
yeah why is that weird floaty thing
happening
well it's the same
so the only difference between those two
on the bottom is that the top one
doesn't have
an outer border
okay all right so that is
and that's another question do we want
that or not that's that's the way tim
specified it
terms first five what the same without
the outer border yeah yeah
okay but i think if it doesn't have an
outer border you've got to change that
that i don't love the
double border but if it had a outer
border but no
um panel border it might look nice
but the problem with the panel border is
that you've got to enclose the scroller
maybe or it just sets next to i mean it
might not look bad without
it the scroller would be just next to
the panel
i wouldn't be sorry to lose that outer
border we could have we could have an
option
to make it disappear okay we could just
lose it entirely
how does it look when you get small
without the outer border
you mean small magnification
no i mean i mean a small data set lots
of small data sets
did you understand what i'm asking like
a grid of one element data sets or
something
or i mean small enough that doesn't that
it doesn't need the scroll bar
yo that just looks sucky to have a
double border there
why did we put the border in the first
place really to enclose
the scroll bar with the rest of the
content so it all looks like one thing
but i agree with um the jeremy i don't
really
understand the purpose i think let's try
removing it
it would be clearly associated with the
data set it was just approximately fine
well let's try removing it
okay but but let's go back to what are
we trying to achieve with these themes
okay so
i'm can somebody explain to me i mean so
we've got things like does it have i
mean so
this one will be kind of without the
outer border
will look kind of clean here
right i mean so there's there's the
horizontal only
separators there's the vertical only
separators
are making sense yeah
and there's both there's three class
there's four four
separator themes horizontal vertical
both
and one called group dividers which only
it's all dividers except at the lowest
level so the lowest level row and column
blocks are not divided
okay okay then we've also got
background colors alternating background
colors for example for different
like like you've done here right
um okay
we're also trying to bring some color to
the whole thing
we do not think we want to color the
main content correct
although we might have a background for
the main content
do you understand what i'm asking uh
yeah
yeah i i think i agree with that
statement that you don't want to color
the main content
you know with the exception of you know
like if you have a dark background then
it
presumably needs to be you know light
text for the main content
can you reevaluate that web input
there's a bug here that i fixed oh yeah
whatever
um those dark headers should line up
with the darkened
uh rose but it's that's offline
okay can you do that one again with the
titanic
just to have
another view of it
um
that looks nicer not much less of a mess
than this one
i mean this one has many reasons why
it's a mess so
chris this these things here they need
to have styling right
yeah i agree
um
honestly this doesn't look that bad to
me
although i don't quite know i mean again
design folk what do you think about
these i mean
if we weren't in that heading to
something which has if we're going to
reverse out like that we're going to
have to have reasonably bold type
true or not true that's true
but if it's you know a bla a dark font
on a lighter background would you go
with this that semi bulb oh i i
understand
but but the question is
okay
how can you choose how all the text is
aligned in each cell type can't you just
say alignments in here
now yeah item you say alignment or
header alignment
so alignment if i say alignment arrow
right here
it'll just align like that
i see and then header alignment deals
with the headers
okay uh
there's comments about exporting to
latex and so on which we should support
more
i don't know what um i mean the the does
anybody have any idea what this will do
if i say
export this to um export string to
i have html tried that
this is not looking promising i was
going to say abort it and do it to html
fragment
that looks really horrifying
that did nothing
that's just that that's just the raw
data it just didn't do anything at all
so that's a that's a serious problem
which we need to address
um
well that's an interesting point from
ethan make them look good in style
notebooks as well
that's everybody's just making it hard
for us but that's okay
um that's a question for tim with
respect to the plot themes
how how well have we investigated that
investigation the thing i was just
mentioning the the
in a style notebook right i mean i think
we are planning to
rework the notebook styles
but the question is if i do this if i
styled my notebook here
um with
i don't know what report
confidential report i don't even know
what that means that's not very exciting
um you know how well do these work well
that wasn't very exciting
um
what happens if i go yes it's slide
shows
okay no that journal one should be fine
yeah go ahead and do a plain plot in
that notebook now
oh yeah i just whoops oh that one
command
the default yeah
copy the cell yeah okay
so that inherited a plot theme from the
style sheet right right
the default plot theme looks at what the
style sheet is
um and there's themes for like earth
and garnet and all those they're the
slideshows
and so if i if i use the slideshow
yeah any of those
you have to realize do that plot you
just reevaluate it
yeah so you get different colors and you
get different fonts
good work it's nice
and and so what does that gonna do for
data set
have you i mean i don't know if it does
but conceivably it can do the same thing
right um
by the way we probably we called it
reverse color just
millions of years ago it will be dark
mode the the name for the style sheet
there okay um
okay are these our internal ones
are these do they ship with the product
are they just
or something okay um
[Music]
some of those may actually ship with the
product
i mean they're the versions that are
used by the documentation
when you're in the dock viewer okay all
right okay
okay let's try and uh disentangle this
okay so we've got first point is we
don't like the verdana font it's too
bold
that's probably not going to be useful
for any case
okay second point um
let's you have got these sub
options down here okay so
these font themes
okay so let's look through some of these
okay so we agreed these are code fonts
and they're wrong
right so the default will be the source
science pro
does that make sense to everybody yes
okay so small small items large items i
think that's interesting
um these are all interesting if the
fonts were more sensible they'd be
they'd look good i think uh
okay does anybody want to to these look
good to me
um any comments jeremy
i'm looking for sans-serif or italic
serif i'm not sure that's there
but the variance on serif should be
there
i see
so can you mix them together yeah using
them together is fine but
yeah um that's not currently implemented
i'm i had it implemented and there were
some problems i need to fix it but you
should be able to combine like italic
and sands
okay fine so sometimes that's documented
that seems okay to me
now where do we have the relative
coloration of the
headers is that coming the relative
coloration of the headers and the
content
uh you mean a theme i mean i mean one of
these
one of these themes oh i see these are
just naked themes here
so all right these are feature themes
that are meant to be combined i
understand it so i'm i'm looking for a
feature theme
that has to do with
header backgrounds yes so color theme
the color feature themes right we don't
have any of those
other than the base themes that
determine header colors
okay but so i don't think that's right
okay so so what are we doing in
in this case here we're doing
these colors what's that we there there
are
parametric uh background themes you can
specify colors of
uh the background striping and the
header striping
i don't know i'm asking in in plots how
do we do that
in the background color obviously say
background arrow or whatever in a plot
right yeah you do something in dataset
there is a
background color that automatically
colors things based on the background
color it's at the top of your doc
notebook
your help viewer
menu with a color there you're saying
here
right yeah or it finds the actual
notebook background color but i mean if
i were to say here
you know background arrow
blue or something oh god
that's what you asked for well i
understand that but
it's it's it's it's doing
the background only for the content area
right there's header background for the
headers okay so i mean i suppose we
could have themes that coordinate the
two
okay so let's say i have header
background
okay so notice by the way that we've got
trouble with these
what are we going to call these things
are they footers i mean i'm wondering
you know is that style the same style as
you know the more stuff at the bottom of
a large data set
i mean it's the same idea yeah no no no
does it should it be the same style
should they be differently named
because we've got to get something which
switches the style of this
right yeah because this is obviously
wrong we've got to be able to switch
that style
we've got to be able to so what again
what are we calling
these you know extenders openers
so i'm saying i mean that could be
called an opener background or something
but i don't know whether that's the
right
or openness style but we don't what
other things
do we have a header style yeah
okay so we could call this something
like opener style
for these things yeah
what would we call the thing at the
bottom then
you're talking about the paginator this
thing yes yeah
well maybe we should call it paginator
open a style paginator style and just
have
have a single option like that is it
pagination though i mean it's more of
jump points in his continuous scroll
right
what well i i don't think these are
pages right can't you scroll it on a
long list it would jump to uh
well the paginator has grown
like navigator or something instead of
paginator
yeah a navigator is awfully general
although we might be able to reuse it
for other things i mean the other thing
we've got that's coming
of the same type is the uh in
notebook uh repository browser
which might use the very same technology
that we have here
okay so we got those things all right so
now let's keep going
you've got your font themes you've got
divider themes
okay that's what you were talking about
row dividers column dividers
group dividers okay
and there isn't a sense of of
alternating dividers or some such other
thing
that doesn't make any sense no it
doesn't really make any sense now okay
so what do you call the thing which
looks like an old line printer
with the alternating color backgrounds
well there's an example down below of a
parametric
no no i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about something look there is a
standard thing which we could call line
printer
at least us old fogies know what we're
talking about but you're talking about
like a like a base style but it's
alternating rows right but the rows are
just the main
key values i would expect that you know
to have an example under background
themes
at the bottom of you know the next
screen full of them
okay
so there are a lot of background themes
the main ones are row backgrounds column
backgrounds and full which means row and
columns
and those stripe the top level rows and
columns
i don't think that's the right name for
this
i think it would be alternating rows or
something alternating columns or some
such other thing
because row background suggests to me
that it's
you know it doesn't suggest this
alternation thing
yeah although i mean what else are you
going to do with rose so there's an
alternate background
so well i'm sorry what are you saying i
mean what else would you do with
backgrounds other than alternate
i have no idea but row backgrounds
doesn't tell me it's alternating
i mean row backgrounds i i probably
wouldn't think that hard and i would
think this is going to be the background
color of all rows
see what i'm saying
um i kind of think the alternation is
what matters now this thing here
okay but this alternation the
alternation color
i see the color is being determined by
something else okay
fine i this fall doesn't make it for me
i mean alternating
what do we do when we want to say both
of them
it's probably something like that
what's detailed row backgrounds so
detailed stripes the lowest level rose
i would never have figured that out yeah
well may not be the best name but i
okay all right okay so what what name
should we use for that
why is that concept useful
well if you i mean in this case if you
want the moon individual moons to be
described
rather than just the top level of
planets that's how you would do it
and why would i want that
can you do that planets data set
with just regular row backgrounds
just so i can see what it actually does
yeah
it's it's it doesn't it just doesn't
stretch
i mean take out the detail oh i see
i don't understand what this did i just
don't understand this i mean
it's not it's doing every other planet
is striped
darker okay so it's at the top level
right so so you were using the word
detailed
oh boy so okay so this strikes the top
level
right as opposed to striping all levels
no
detailed stripes the leaves i understand
i'm pointing at this one here
this stripes the the top of the tree
yeah yeah
correct yes is there anything that
stripes
every element of the tree yes it's
called hierarchical
does it look reasonable or is it just
totally silly i don't
if you know for shallow like two level
data sets it might be useful when it
gets deep it's really hard
it's just there's an interesting
gradation that it creates
yeah i mean with colors that might with
a cut is there a way of making a color
map here
uh you can specify is parametric you can
[Music]
if you put it put a list around
hierarchical full backgrounds and then
put
a row color and a column color
so up until it uses transparency if you
put a red filter in front of a green
filter you get black
so i mean typically you would use a
lighter background for colors
okay so let's say i say lightning yeah
that'll be better
okay i see so it's combining
using rgb combination so to speak
it's it's treating them like filters
um
yeah obviously saying that the colors
look like they're based on exclusive
wall
but they're actually it's actually it's
multiplying the color channels
i see which is
essentially just applying transparency
um okay ethan is commenting
on tech based
tables are beautiful apparently
well this is not this is some
some of these i think are more beautiful
than others
i don't consider these all that
beautiful
okay i mean that's
kind of ugly
i'm learning that much here
okay nothing notable that i should be
looking at here
i'm not seeing anything terribly
remarkable but i mean
notice this use of these uh
these kinds of lines which are not sure
i've seen with our stuff
understand what i'm saying yeah the
dotted lines with the heavy lines are
nice
that's interesting it's a simple
structure though we're looking at really
complicated
data structures right but that that is
the case with dotted line separators we
have not seen here
chris can you respond to that please um
you
you can do that actually you can do that
now because there's a parameterization
of the divider style so you can specify
the style
okay but then then we should i mean look
we're trying to inventory
what kinds of forms are interesting so
that's one that's interesting it's a
dotted
divider right there's also these heavy
you know things around the headings and
so on how would we do that
um so dividers are difficult
because we only have local information
we don't really know what's around
an element so there are some things we
can do with dividers or some things we
can't because we just don't have the
information
it depends on that no no but but but i'm
asking a specific question
right you see here the header right the
header
is being identified by having basically
lines above and below it
yeah we can do that okay how do we do
that well it's
we can do it in a theme there's no top
level
option to do that because it's
you know i don't know a general way of
easy way of doing that
i'm sorry i don't understand that what
we're talking about here
so the way the dividers are implemented
there's a method option
with horrible um
code that does dividers based on the
local information for each cell
okay so it's complicated it's
complicated by the fact that within a
grid
each successive cell overwrites the left
and the bottom
divide a frame of the previous cell so
it gets really horrible to
to specify these things so
you mean it it's posit it is order
dependent because
you have to deal with you are you are a
box
you are a cell in this grid and you have
four walls so to speak
that are shared with the neighboring
cells right and and you have arguments
with your neighbors
yeah okay but what you are doing
is a left left right top bottom
scan of these things therefore you are
overwriting your neighbor's walls is
that correct
yes okay
but also you can also instruct a cell to
leave its neighbor's wall untouched
so the neighbor the preceding neighbor
can make the decision and you can
you can decide to let the decision stand
it doesn't always overwrite okay but so
a given cell
can take responsibility for all four of
its walls
or for its default two walls or for no
walls at all
or whatever right yes it can take a
responsibility for all four but it
doesn't know what's gonna happen to the
right at the bottom
and the neighbors determine that
um
okay
so okay hold on let's
let's so i mean the among the things
that we're not doing so show me how
to do for example dividers that are
dotted
um if you scroll down there's an example
of a parameterized
thing you could go on parametric things
right
so open let's just open on
the bottom one is there's your computer
paper
right so you just stick in the dot oh
okay hold on hold on hold on so we've
got something
which is like those heavy dividers
except that here we've got heavy
dividers for everything
yeah this is right this is really good
i understand that but so how do we put
in we need a concept of header dividers
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
no
okay i can ignore the absolute thickness
there
that's kind of nice i mean it's not very
nice the way it goes through that that
gray
there but i think using dotted dividers
is nice
yeah so i mean maybe that becomes
a um um
i mean it needs to behave similar to you
know how the
background stuff was done where
you know it was either from the top or
from the bottom or i mean i guess
you really do want to separate out
dividers versus content
i mean headers versus content
so so so okay so if we say
i mean this row dividers here so this is
now saying
okay that's a that's a sub option of
data set
theme so i can also say something like
um actually no i'm saying here
header i can only say header background
i can't say
there's no notion of header no dividers
currently there could be yeah but i mean
so that could be done in the same way
as this as this row dividers thing
but so what does it mean the default is
to have row
and column dividers is it not yes
so if i say column column dividers why
is that also
why is that not also getting i
understand what what that's going to do
do you understand what i'm asking why
does it make sense to have if i just say
row dividers
why does it not default to having column
dividers
because row dividers means only row
dividers
okay that's this is like a high level
theme that means
i only want row dividers okay all right
it sounds like what you're asking for is
you want separate control over the row
dividers and the column dividers
it seems a little weird
okay
let me see so okay
we really have to resolve this stuff
right now right because we're trying to
get all this stuff into 12.3
right yeah so we got to keep going here
so my next meeting needs to get pushed
back
and also the people in it need to
actually do what they were supposed to
do first
um
i mean we could we could split the
divider themes like i have the other
ones in item
and row versions there are items
item and header versions
yeah we need a note padded panel frame
option i agree
look i think we're just going to drop
this out of frame i mean maybe it can be
a method option to put back in the outer
frame
make sense do you have a method option
right now that can remove the outer
frame
no okay so we need to get that in there
okay so among the things that we're
describing here we need a header
dividers
but i don't know what we're dividers
[Music]
um
and what does header dividers see
because that's what's confusing row
dividers
says switch off column dividers
you see what i'm saying which is a very
weird thing for it to mean
i'm saying most of the things here are
no it doesn't mean switch off row
dividers
it means no it says turn on column
dividers
no we have row dividers by default
so when you say row dividers it means
switch off column dividers
see what i'm saying if i were to
not see that you're confused too
if i take that out i've got both row and
column dividers
you see what i'm saying okay so this is
saying
switch off the other dividers
now i see what you're saying but it
makes perfect sense it does make some
sense
like only column dividers
yeah row dividers
i don't know that's that's useful but
but it is reasonably clear but but
you guys are missing no no what do we do
with header dividers
do you understand because what we want
to say is put
in header dividers right how do we
specify that
can you have header row dividers and
header column dividers
perhaps yes
well but so but but by default
see we we want to have heavier header
row dividers that's the interesting
cases to have those be heavier you
understand what i'm saying
yeah so what are the different
categories of things that we have
we have headers we have items
we have rows we have columns
headers well rows and columns are not
really distinct
i mean maybe they are headers i mean
because we also could potentially have
different kinds of headers
we could have row headers column headers
right and i'm just trying to figure out
what our terminology is
because it affects our naming oh i know
it's a mess
right so what is a row
because an item is both in a row and in
a column is it not
so a row is a collective of items
am i am i correct
is that correct well headers and items
okay so a row means both the headers and
the items
on that row yes
okay
okay sorry sorry bret pl please keep
going so i mean
row headers and column headers
see see okay basic categories which
label cells right so there's two
different things they could be labeling
they could be labeling cells
and they could be labeling the borders
of cells
are they labeling groups of cells
yes right so
it has to decide which of those it is
um
so under what circumstances do we want
to label cells
when are we labeling cells and all of
the styling
ever
i'm not sure what you mean but i'm
asking you when we give
fighters no label meaning name
for in the name of the theme
yeah okay right when the theme
is specifying itself the theme
says the theme is going to probably be
of the form
you know thing action
see what i'm saying thing style or
something
did you get what i'm saying like header
but it isn't that's not what you've
consistently done
so internally the basic division
is there's column there's row headers
there's column headers there's
items and there are corner headers okay
so
let's write that down it says row head
and column headers what are the other
ones
items and corner headers
and i guess additionally we'll have um
like paginator and opener
well it may or may not be called
pagerank but yeah okay i hope not
okay okay fine so for example the corner
headers if i wanted to decorate this
with some
you know medieval illumination how would
i do that
well i can't well i i don't mean
that seriously but i mean you know
change its color for example
there's no top-level way to change the
corner header independently of the other
things
okay but so if i were to specify the row
headers and the column headers
what color does the corner header get
left it it belongs to the
to the uh column headers it's
essentially a header for that column of
row headers
okay but you're choosing to name it
differently
yeah because they're kind of in styling
you want to treat them as a separate
piece
but you just said you couldn't restyle
them differently
not at top level i can do it internally
are there any themes that say leave that
corner header blank
even though the row headers and the
column headers are styled
well there's like minimal yeah
okay so if i say data theme
by the way the fact that that predictive
interface
showed nothing in that case is really
kind of unfortunate
you see what i'm saying it should
certainly show the re
re styling of the data set if not making
the
normal data set and all those kinds of
things makes sense
okay i i meant are there anywhere like
the row and
header columns row and column headers
are you know like have a colored
background but the
corner one doesn't no okay
okay let's come back over here okay so
we've got
we've got these elements
oh boy
um all right
we gotta we gotta be organized here
we've been jumping around like crazy
let's by the way
how many of these themes are also
supported for grids
none
are we going to do that
i mean as far as i know the grid does
not have beams
but isn't this implemented using grid
yeah but not
by i mean yes it is
but so you shouldn't have to go into all
of the data set
you know stuff to get theming for a grid
should you
the grid doesn't have any notion of
headers does it yeah i mean
it takes advantage of a lot of
information about an item you know
whether it's a header
row header column header what level it's
at
you know what index in the row there's a
lot of information all right fair enough
fair enough okay all right let's go back
up here again
okay okay
okay so we we have not resolved how to
get
these separator lines around the headers
but not around other things
have we
did do you understand what i'm asking
yeah
okay that's one of the things we need to
resolve um
we've also not resolved
you know i kind of feel like we should
be more explicit with some of these
things because i think it's going to be
incomprehensible otherwise
if we say color alternating rose
at least then we have a fighting chance
of knowing what that might mean
making sense i mean i i don't think you
need the alternating i think that
i don't agree with you i don't agree
with you if you say color rose
it means to me take every row and make
it green
you know this idea of alternation is is
you know it's a different idea
right but i mean my take on this and my
idea is that
you shouldn't be you should rarely be
seeing
color alter you know color rose
on its own and have to know what it
means
well fine right i mean the usual way
that you would see this
is on the right hand side of an option
completion
at which point we have the ability to
just show you what it's going to look
like
well then why don't we give it an
explicit name if it's going to be
auto-completed anyway
let's not give it an obscure name
because if this is if this is something
when you look up the definition of some
particular data set theme
and you see this thing in it you want to
know what it is
i think you're giving all the arguments
for why this should be as explicit as
possible
well there's one argument on why it
shouldn't
which is that if you look at the
documentation notebook for plot theme
that you have there
i guess there's enough space but you
know oh that's a
ridiculous argument that depends on how
verbose you get
that argument's already dead um okay
okay let's talk about headers again
okay so we've got four
okay so we we have the possibility of
are we confusing themes and options
it almost seems like we're trying to
design options
to specify you know row
row header row dividers and row header
column dividers
those are not really themes
no they're not that they would be used
in themes
they're not i mean this is why
we might actually want an option called
header dividers right just like we have
an option called dividers
right we have an option called header
background right
is that correct yes yes okay
so maybe we want header dividers just
like we have dividers and background we
want
header dividers and header background
that making sense yeah
and so then header dividers would
presumably be
the dividers above and below a header
well why not left and right
well i mean it's okay
okay so dividers right now
if you want only row dividers what do
you do is it true false or something
well you mean for a grid no no no no no
no here's no dividers option for dataset
really yes how come
thinks there is and there never has been
well it thinks there is
no no i turned off syntax
because oh
okay okay what is the okay i mean i
think we have this
you know a fundamental issue of
what things apply to data set and what
things apply to grid
and you know what things we expect
i don't understand why the grid options
shouldn't be
i see the reason they can't be
applicable to data sets because data set
is a hierarchical structure
even vastly more complicated than grid
yes to specify all of these things
yep
okay well then let's not discuss i mean
that then
then you're saying basically none of
these are options they're all being
stuffed into themes
because it's too complicated to specify
everything in total detail
i mean i assume that you have a fall
through where you can specify everything
in total detail
well there's a there's a method option
that no no that's not what i'm asking
i'm asking
if i want to format the level seven of
my data set
with a grid that has alternating pink
and green
things can i do that exactly is there
some is there some
no no is that but not not dividers yet
there's currently no control over
dividers
backgrounds you can do but dividers for
some reason you cannot do
exactly why
i mean it was never on the agenda okay
that's not a good answer i mean is there
a reason
is there a good reason it can't be done
well it's
not at all straightforward coming up
with the syntax that actually
is understandable and works i understand
but the syntax
in i mean this is obviously a
complicated syntax here
that is dealing with the fact that it's
an off by one type thing
right yeah
i understand why this syntax here
wouldn't work
in the successive levels of dataset
um
seems like it would possibly
i mean that syntax basically assumes
that
it's you know a
nice end by end type of thing
and once you start throwing the spanning
stuff in then it's
oh boy yeah that's complicated i agree
um let's see if i look up header
background
those are very ugly examples
you know eventually we're going to have
to make consistent all these different
functions that have
um you know like table table form has
headers
right is stable form getting
re-implemented as data set
no a table form is a low level thing i
i'm aware of that but
unrelated to data center why
well i mean it's intended to be a
lightweight extremely efficient thing
which is
not what dataset is that's an
implementation detail
why would why would it's an
implementation detail why does it make
any difference i mean
you know we've got a headers option for
table view don't we for table form don't
we
i don't know
is it stable headers that's right
well at least it was a a nice defensive
why did it not come up there as a direct
hit
okay so table headers
table headings oh i see table headings
okay so it's different okay fine it's
different
um
okay so header background
i see it level k all right fine i get it
okay let's go back around again okay
so we've got okay the things we're
trying to achieve
are how do we do something where we have
thicker lines around the headers but the
headers
are styled do you understand what i'm
saying
you understand the point what you're
talking about things like in that tech
yes for example yes yeah
how do we do that
well i i mean i would think we need to
define various classes of dividers
there's header dividers there's the
outer header dividers it's the internal
header dividers
okay so what is your proposal for how we
i mean one possibility
is that in the end we throw in a giant
association of detailed tweaks
that initially could live in the method
option that just say what to do with
each of these different things
which could include the openers the
paginators all that kind of stuff
and then your themes
can sort of bank switch those things
um but in practice i mean for the themes
it's more complicated than that because
in some cases
you know if an item is the outermost
item not preceded by a row header you
want one kind of divider if it's
preceded by a row header you want a
different divider
so that's where it gets complex
okay by the way a point being made by
ethan our live stream here is that
should be possible to
cast a data set into a grid it's an
interesting idea
but actually is it even possible might
not be possible because the way the
headers work and so on
i mean you could translate it into some
sort of grid
i mean it might be a lossy operation
oh sure you wouldn't be able to go back
right but
i mean that's basically what chris is
doing right now right is
yeah with a lot of fluff i mean you
could d fluff it and
spit it out as a grid
um
okay so so my best guess is we would we
would define various
classes of dividers like you know
the divider between the headers and the
content the divider between content
items all those things
and then you would be able to apply a
style of each one
[Music]
yes whether or not whether or not i have
the information internally to actually
support that is another question
because dataset was never never designed
to know
you know what's what's next to what it
just makes it great it has no idea
what's next what
and everything i do with dividers now is
only based on local information so i
know
you know i know an item if it's first in
its row or last in its row
those kinds of things but i don't know
if an item is next to a header
i understand okay so let's say you
wanted to have those
thick lines around the header okay
and you were doing that just at the
level of the theme can you do that
i think i could it's not straightforward
but i think i could
why is it not straightforward because
because otherwise something is going to
step on it from below well
you only want thick lines like above and
below the entire massive headers right
you don't want thick lines between each
level of header
i'm presenting i guess
yes yeah it's those kinds of things that
are triggered no that's tricky
um but yes i can i could do that now
all right so so maybe for a theme name
there could be something that's called
something like
you know header lines or something
that means that that means that one
thing
i've put lines around the header
do you see what i'm saying yeah so we're
not
addressing the micro control of the
third level header gets lines around it
type thing
yeah but another complication in this is
that the
the method option that controls this is
typically implemented as a function
and so if i have two component functions
there's really no way for me to combine
them you know if i
if i'm trying to add header lines to the
to the minimal theme
why don't
are you talking about an implementation
detail inside method options because i
mean i would assume
okay so what you want to do is tease
apart
these various components and recombine
them into one thing
and if they're implemented as functions
it's hopeless
maybe they should be combinators or
something so
i mean maybe what has to happen there is
we have to divide we have to
define these classes of dividers
and make those available via top level
options
and then we can i'm confused about what
you're talking about but
but i mean the goal needs to be
something like this that you say data
set
you know data set me minimal and then
but include header lines
just like you you think you're going to
and then we say you know color
alternating columns right
so first statement is i think it's
important that every
statement here be an affirmative so to
speak
um so this headlines means you're
putting in header lines
right it doesn't mean you're not putting
in some other lines so i think then it
wants to be
um
[Music]
now i mean okay again that's a little
confusing because
there will be some base styles that have
no head no divider lines
and others that do
right so i mean if i then say if there
was a base style that had no
divider lines and then i said uh
row dividers
do you see what i'm saying yeah then
that would say
switch on road of road dividers but not
column dividers
from that base style but if the base
style had both
i would expect row dividers to leave it
unchanged
but i think what we can do that sounds
weird to me
which sounds weird i think we i thought
we had agreed that we were going to say
something like
i mean you know we could also have
things like you know
you know we could have no column
dividers
that's a sensible idea
omits column dividers that's an
affirmative negative
right well that's i mean
because otherwise it's okay but listen
listen listen otherwise what are we
going to do it depends on the base style
what column dividers might i mean you
know does it mean drop row dividers or
not
right that will depend on the base style
right does it or does it not depend on
the base style chris
yes wait a minute so
your column dividers mean something
different if
the base style contains growing column
dividers yes
no no oh boy
okay so that's incomprehensible
basically
so to me these things have to be able to
you know
there is a base style has certain things
switched on so
these sort of
declarations have to switch on and off
things relative to the base style
is that right or is that not how you're
thinking about it that's not how i was
thinking about it i mean
i was thinking of dividers as just
monolithic things you can specify a
divider style
okay but is that the only thing you're
thinking about in that way
um well
the background styles are
pretty much the same way yeah
like separate control of rowan and
column
backgrounds other than via the full
background's
style or a theme which gives you both
row and
column alternating backgrounds
but that's not incomprehensible you
can't combine our
you know row backgrounds with column
backgrounds it's either one or the other
they don't
they don't merge they don't combine yeah
i know i think that's super confusing
given those names
again i don't think backgrounds is the
right name for something which is
fundamentally alternating
by the way it could even odd alternate
or odd even alternate
well actually you can yeah you can make
them cyclic too
you can specify a list of colors
by giving a second thing
instead of giving a single color you can
give a list of colors
what do you mean you mean in a list so
you're saying there's an example at the
bottom
okay i i understand but i'm trying to
understand what you're doing you're
saying row dividers and i say
no no
it's plural backgrounds plural yes yeah
right okay so that just alternates with
the with the default background
so so wait a minute so red and that red
is really red and none is that correct
well red and it's white no no but it
should be none right
there's no background so it should be
none shouldn't it shouldn't change
the background if there's a background
specified for the whole thing
it should be neutral it should be the
same as the background for the whole
thing
right
yeah okay okay but so so this is then
okay so what you're saying is if i just
say row backgrounds
i am effectively getting a default that
says
uh row backgrounds something like light
gray
none is that correct yeah
yes okay but very bizarrely row
backgrounds on its own
also switches column backgrounds
to presumably pure
well what would it be none none or what
yeah and that's syntax but what what is
it in another syntax
well there is there is no syntax for
saying no
column backgrounds i mean row
backgrounds is
a style in which only the rows have
alternating backgrounds
that's the intent it's not a component
it's just
the overall look but it is a component
because it goes along with the marketing
style for example
well some some use the prepackaged
background styles and some
have their own
i understand but which whatever it has i
i've got to do this mix
in of saying oh and give me row
backgrounds as well
in minimal style or whatever else it is
right
yes it'll mix in with things like
dividers and header styles
and such but it won't mix in with other
background
themes okay so what wins
the base theme or something or this
thing
the if you specify a base theme and a
row backgrounds in addition
the rope you'll get row backgrounds it
will
supersede what's in the basement okay so
it wins
yes okay but you cannot specify row
backgrounds one thing and call them back
on something else and get both row and
column backgrounds
i know because of the way you specified
row and column backgrounds which i don't
think is right
okay and i mean in your full backgrounds
thing god knows what the
you know you have a matrix as the second
element there
is a tiled matrix that you have or tiled
tensor
that you have it's just it's just row
row colors and column colors
no no no no no oh you mean in in the
full you're talking about the
parameterization
i'm talking about the full backgrounds
case
the parameters yeah i'm talking about
what you give us the colors in the full
backgrounds case
right you get the row color and the
column so you give a sequence of row
colors and then a sequence of column
colors
if you want more than one yes
okay and those are just interspersed so
okay
all right fine okay
uh okay look we're
okay what did we we
started off just not being very happy
with the coloring of these things
colors and fonts of these things right
and then we start i mean like something
like this i don't really understand this
but what
yeah i don't really understand this at
all i don't understand why that
separator didn't go up higher
because it's a separator for that second
level
well i mean is that gap because you know
if that outer frame goes away
as we've discussed then that
separator would basically be
no sorry never i don't think i don't
think the art of frame going away will
look terrible in this case i don't think
that thing will seem like it's floating
because it has this thing
it always will have a divider unless you
switch off all these unless you switch
off these header dividers basically
it will always have something which is
spanning up to it correct
at that level
okay so let's go back through this
all right
we've understood that there need to be
some internal options for the opener
style the paginator style and navigator
style
right okay um and wait you said internal
options you don't want those to be top
level
just like header style i don't think we
should yet
i think we should just have people look
look this is unbelievably complicated to
switch
as we as we can see from this whole
discussion right we spent an hour
talking about these details
i think for most people what's going to
matter
is you know that there are good
themes that they can switch into banks
switch into am i making sense that was
my philosophy
right so you know because the details
are really quite complicated and a lot
of things you want think of and it's
just a big mess
right so you're proposing these should
be method options but
opener style page i think so for now yes
i mean if it turns out
people really love having you know being
able to orange theme their
their paginators or navigators or
whatever then so be it
okay um okay
so then we've got
uh the other options that we were
complaining about
are these
yeah this row backgrounds column
backgrounds oh gosh
um
how can we deal with that that row
backgrounds implicitly implies no
column no alternating column backgrounds
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
well qualifying it with only seemed
no i don't think that's the right thing
it's not getting across alternating
which we really need to have
well actually i mean alternating row
backgrounds
see but i don't understand why that why
then
okay what what does alternating row
backgrounds do again
it gives you alternating backgrounds for
the top level roads
so that's what you have in that light
table on the left right yeah
so jupiter has one background saturn has
one background
etc right and why does okay
so that just goes at the top level so it
sprays itself
down into the first into all satellites
of
of uh neptune for example whatever it is
all satellites of jupiter get sprayed of
color
right
okay and and then you've got a different
do you have any way of saying
i want it only on the top level that is
the
jupiter level things but not on the sub
pieces over here for the moons
okay right because those are still in
that row
right they have it and so it picks up
that row background
okay so again alternating row
backgrounds
were the base style to set a column
background
are you seriously imagining that
alternating row background switches off
the column backgrounds
that's the way it's currently
implemented yes
i propose it doesn't work that way i
propose that the
the base styles
i mean so the the thing is that the base
styles
are an amalgamation of feature styles
yeah and
well which they're not in this case
because the feature styles
have this exclusionary characteristic so
what you're saying is there would not be
any full backgrounds they would you
would combine
exactly that's what i'm saying because
because the statement that brett made is
not correct with your current design
that is in what brett said is every
feature thing you throw in
is a is an extra thing that contributes
to what you see
well it's more complicated than that
right i mean so if you go back to the
plot theme documentation yeah
um and this aspect of it
isn't you know really
documented and i don't know that you
know we've
you know it's some it's not something
that has confused people you know very
often if at all
is like for those axis features you know
there's eight of them or whatever
one of those is active at a time
i understand so if you started on a
theme you're saying
i see what you're saying so in fact
it's not all being thrown into a vat and
then rendered the way it's being told to
render what's instead happening
is that these things are the exclusive
you know they're hitting radio buttons
effectively
yeah effectively and what happens is
internally there you know things get
weighted
and so there's a weight for
you know a base theme which is pretty
low
you know like point y or something you
know but if you specify an actual
feature you know specific feature theme
that is a higher weight and
you know as such it will overrule
whatever lower weighted feature theme
was part of the base theme
right and data set themes are
implemented the same way
okay
well so i mean we can i
i can think about whether it's
technically possible
to implement these component rules well
i'm not sure it's right
i'm not sure it's necessary right i mean
so
i don't think that the switching off you
know
i just think okay so look alternating
row backgrounds would probably do it for
me
i like that okay so you're just changing
row backgrounds to alternating row
backgrounds
um and i i have to say i like
alternating out front
you know better than it being in the
middle yes
all right fine all right alternating row
backgrounds alternating column
backgrounds
and the very obscure alternating row
column backgrounds
which is a very obscure case
does that make sense to people no
okay all right so that's that all right
we finally got that
okay now let's talk about the headers
okay so
what about what about the other
background themes
which are what which are hierarchical
and detail
so detailed is the alternating but at
the
bottom level instead of the top level is
that right yes
oh boy
and what's hierarchical again that's all
levels with things combining via
transparency
and then i also have separate
things for headers and for items now
those can be combined
what do you mean how does it work
separate things so you can you can
specify
you can specify like uh alternating
header
backgrounds and alternating
item backgrounds you can specify those
things separately and they combine
okay but alternating row backgrounds
four headers operating alternating row
backgrounds
four items is what you're saying
and those are distinguished from the
other themes by by the word header
item and name
sorry said it again those are qualified
by putting
headers or items in the name in the
theme
so it's it's row backgrounds and row
header backgrounds or row item
backgrounds
row backgrounds does both row item only
applies to items row header replies
why are you likely to want i
see okay all right boy okay so that
becomes
alternating row item backgrounds
yes okay so now the question is what
happens on the drill down for the for
the detailed thing
oh boy
for that could we just have a second
argument only you know list second
arguments the
the level like a negative one for the
end or all
defaults to the first level
well i could imagine the word leaf
in the in the initial thing so i mean
alternating
leaf row backgrounds
is it relevant for both headers and and
content items
well uh yeah
the um so
you can you can alternate just the
leaves or you could also imagine
alternating the
leaf headers along with the leaf rose
which i think is actually useful
see what i'm what i'm saying
so in other words for the for the moon
entry and the planet's data set
yep you'd have the mass and radius items
but you also might want to alternate
so i mean so then we have a very long
complicated thing but that's life
i mean so we then have alternating
uh
row alternating leaf
row headers backgrounds is that right
row header backgrounds
[Music]
alternating leaf row header backgrounds
well it might at least be comprehensible
i mean not many people are going to see
that
but i think that's okay
working on line wrapping that table yet
yeah well um okay
alternating all row header backgrounds
for the other case for what you're
calling hierarchical
is that right is that the cur
so alternating row header back row
backgrounds is the top level
leaf is the leaf all is all
that makes sense yeah okay
all right what else do we have so we
have to figure out the thing with
dividers
right
i mean i think the thing with the
dividers is
you know we replace backgrounds with
dividers and unfortunately we
you know can't do everything yet
well no because rollback the basic
classes are
for both headers and items we have
the outer dividers and the internal
dividers
and then we have the horizontal and the
vertical dividers
so i think we want a syntax where you
can identify those different classes and
then apply
different styling to them
and i'm talking about options rather
than themes
and maybe method options well i think
what we should be talking about there is
is options whose value is an association
because that's how we've done that's how
we're now doing these things that have
incredibly detailed settings
see what i'm saying so it would be
dividers arrow internal
horizontal headers yeah i mean what i
think it would look like is something
like this dividers
arrow internal
arrow blah blah blah outer arrow blah
blah blah blah blah
that would be a typical thing to do no
i think that's readable
and then you know presumably background
wait a minute i'm now confused what is
the background option again
there's background and there's header
background i see so
background could conceivably be some
complicated thing with this
syntax for those right for which
i know i know but it's possible that um
um
it's possible and i think we've had some
success with this of
that even though there is a positional
list-based
way of specifying things that we also
provide
an association-based way with named keys
which are different syntaxes for the
same
semantics that's correct for example we
did that in cellulose thomason fairly
successfully
i'll show you an example there
why what's there something wrong with
this selection here
that's not selecting it is selecting
it's just not drawing properly it's
reported like
four times and is known
that's why we haven't released 12.3 yet
okay so here we go so this is this is a
specification the following keys can be
used so this is a specification this is
a
the first thing there is a positional
specification
okay which works fine except it can get
quite complicated right this is a
slightly differently sort of
bank-switched
association-based specification okay
okay i think it's a decent design
pattern
um okay but so so
probably the very detailed dividers
thing we'll do this way
but what you've got right now are i want
dividers for rows i don't want them for
columns
correct yes
okay so
do we want to do that by saying row
dividers only
column dividers only i think that's a
reasonable thing to do
and with the radio button type approach
it is effectively looking which is
essentially this is exactly the design
you've got right now it's just a rename
yeah
right are you okay with that
uh i'm fine with the name change yeah i
mean
yeah you know we can we can do these
simpler divider themes initially and
roll out
a more complex dividers option in the
subsequent version right
okay so then i would say we should also
have dotted dividers
would be useful well you so you do that
by
okay that means all dividers dotted
i mean you can do that with a parametric
by adding a
an argument to the theme currently well
so
that'll be row dividers only and then
dotted
i think we should have a dotted dividers
option just that just makes all of them
dotted all the ones that aren't
all the item dividers maybe that's
dotted item dividers
so i'm saying yeah
okay then we need
um
i think we should just have this thing
called header lines and you should do it
the best you can
that would mean what or
horizontal lines above and below the
group of headers
i think so what about vertical headers
what about the headers on the left
column
oh yeah i would like to suggest another
thing
strong headers and weak headers
okay what do i mean by that what i mean
by that is there are cases in which i
really want the headers to stand out
relative to the rest of the the table
and there are cases where i want the
headers to really hang back
relative to the rest so is the current
default is that weak headers or do you
mean even weaker
no i think the current default is i mean
this one is like mega strong headers
the current default no i would say the
current default is
is intermediate
wherever we have it because this is the
link would be like
light gray yes i mean that it's really
gray it's just
a caption right it's a like let me give
you an example
where you want weak headers okay let's
say that the
rows are uuids you see what i'm saying
or the rows are just
you know a number one two three four
five and those numbers are just like
who cares right they're they're like you
want them their detail
but that's not what you want to stand
out so you want them to be weaker than
the content
that's right and the other case is
the rows of the main event you know
let's say
it's the list of the of the great
uh you know bungee jumpers
of the whatever and it's a list of and
the and the
you know the names down here are the
names of the bungee jumpers
and these details here are just you know
uh how many bridges they jumped off or
whatever
you know what i'm saying yeah right
where the sort of the main event
is the is the headers yeah
um
i think uh
i can imagine wanting to go
as well you know weak column headers
weak row headers
you see what i'm saying strong row
headers yeah
now you know in an infinitely
complicated case
it's hierarchical and there's all kinds
of layers to it but let's not worry
about that for now
yeah well i haven't implemented it yet
but on my future agenda is
just like in other options you can
specify the global things
you can also specify things qualified by
paths you can do the same thing for
themes
you can direct a theme at a sub dataset
okay
well that's nice okay so
let's see so in terms of actual coloring
and so on
um you know in a case like this if we're
going to have these bright colors we
have got to have a background color here
in my view i know whether jeremy and tim
would like to comment on this
this just looks wrong right now it's too
contrasting
i don't think white is the right color
though
anybody are you thinking an equally
strong color are you just thinking
like a light gray no i'm thinking of
something like this
i don't know whether jeremy is still
with us well yeah i don't know about
yellow but but something would be good
there
right right that's the only point i was
making yellow isn't necessarily the
right color
yeah if you want but
do like very light blue or light light
blue
uh
um okay
let's see
okay well anyway it's something like
that and should the
background of those uh openers match the
content i was thinking earlier
not quite but they certainly shouldn't
be white like that
but an opacity of the header would be
interesting and it inherits
along the way that would be kind of nice
yes how do you mean that well so you
take the
background color and give it a
percentage of opacity for the
contents so that you consider mass
overlying the moon setter is that what
you mean
um the content so the the contents of
mass and radius in those first two
columns would be
light blue but the right the moon's mass
and radius those would be
you know the reddish orange but lighter
oh i see what you mean like okay
um
okay so look i think you guys need to do
some work on these on these colors
because these these are really not
looking very good i mean this
just looks crummy i mean maybe the fonts
don't help it i mean i think that you
know 62 more items or whatever
is what kills it
he's here yeah i think it's pretty ugly
even without that i think this is like
this is like the gray is too dark
relative to the
color on top of it which i understand is
a quantity so it's lighter
um now in terms of these light styles
like this
that's sort of okay the fighters could
be a little bit heavier
maybe i mean i mean well maybe not once
ugly
address the boldness of yeah the font
change will help that one in that case a
lot
yeah what what is the reason for styling
the quantities different
why are they in a warm gray text rather
than black i don't know
i don't think it makes a lot of sense
that causes some problems because some
backgrounds why are we doing this black
test
well that's the way i inherited it i
don't know what the reason for that
decision was
does jose here does he maybe know
i don't i don't know i think it might be
a mistake
it just seems kind of weird to me and it
causes problems well let's
let's try not let's try not doing it
is that style different from the
defaults
for quantities or yeah it does
it's a warm gray font going on but
quantities don't look like
other types of text output but in this
case we're saying they should right
yeah i mean you know i i agree with that
you see that it has a
quantity attached yeah right and by the
way that trailing period
really should be dropped so that about
500 times
right isn't there a number form isn't
that what our decimal form thing do it
does now
we don't do it in decimal form we do it
in percent form
but i'm not sure with quantity i think
it's important to know that quantities
are real
in other cases like percent form i fully
agree with you
i don't know i don't think kilometers i
don't think anybody expects kilometers
to measure to the
you know to the precise so to speak okay
i'm going to rant for 30 seconds
um i hate the fact that if you do
control equal
3.0 meters it gets turned into three
meters
okay yeah it seems wrong
it's a separate that's a factored
discussion but i think it's one that we
need to have
of dropping the periods in these uh
displayed quantities
it's really not they really don't belong
there if there was a period after it
i mean you built this very elaborate
system for a round
for when you you know for how much stuff
you put in and so on
we just need some basic things for for
this case
okay a round will show that period if
needed
i i know it will but i'm saying this
period is not needed here
that i'm not sure it's very important
that users know that those are reals for
some operations well
for some operations but not in a data
i mean a data set we are is is for
showing is for you know
it's a display form i
i don't think they belong there i think
this is you know if you put them there
then every single time somebody makes a
table for publication they have to go in
and remove those periods
it just doesn't make sense so were you
talking about only for quantities or for
any
any numeric value
well definitely for quantities
right definitely for quantities
you know these things here look
beautiful but this point just looks like
it's
a stupid computer
for example that it has four digits
compared to the previous one which has
like nine digits
so this is a statement of precision
so if we remove it we are making a
statement of being an integer
so suddenly we change from having no
position whatsoever and
after the sixth to infinite position
look it's not infinite precision you're
reading it as infinite precision but i'm
not
right but if we remove it if we remove
that period we convert that
three three eight six into infinitely no
no no no no i'm not suggesting we
convert it to infinite precision
i'm suggesting that in the display we
don't display the period yes but then
then it will read
like i'm infinite but it won't it'll
only read to you like infinite precision
to everybody else they'll just think
it's a number right i mean
the question is what happens if you copy
it out and paste it
well it should be whatever it is
underneath which is a real number
which has a has a you know has the
decimal point and other things in it
what about the decimal points on metas
and drastria's mass
there
i think they're superfluous so and i
think it should be 1.0 times that if it
is 1.0
if it's only one digit precision i think
it should just be 1 times 10 to the 17.
anyway that's a separate discussion
maybe we can put that in an
ild meeting to talk about that yeah
we're going to discuss that
that's a separate thing um but let's
let's try and
we need to wrap up in a moment here but
but
so okay so the next step here we've got
a few details here which chris should
think through and make sure we didn't
move something up horribly
then we've got
you know please just just make a a new
effort
at these styles fair
that's for tim and jeremy okay without
using verdana bold and all this kind of
crazy stuff
right you know bonus points
if we can actually uh try and you know
as i say you're designing to the name
like marketing or whatever else
which is just fine and what you know we
signed up for so to speak
but you know we do need to start coming
up with alternate names to design
to i suspect we should leave what we
have and add new ones
am i making sense yep yeah that's fine
okay so you guys should come up with
some potential names
you know we can start with this kind of
list here
um and
you know okay does it seem like a plan
and you know this has to be turned
around very quickly on chris's part
and others to make it into this you know
to make it now
right okay i think that's
uh probably everything here
so one other item um data set editing
which has been finished essentially
since the end of last year
is being blocked by a front end issue
and john told me today he did not
know whether it was going to get fixed
which i take it to mean it's not going
to get fixed
which would mean data set editing can't
go into 12.3
that's a real shame yeah i think so too
well i mean i don't know there's a lot
of stuff for john to do
yeah i mean how robust is dataset
editing if the front-end feature was
fixed
oh i think i think it's very very robust
it's very nice
if i say so myself kind of can i
can i see it i mean does it work
anywhere uh no it's not on the prototype
i mean i
would have to switch some branches and
restart
things
ethan is suggesting an option a lighted
item format arrow none or whatever else
yeah i agree that that's an issue i mean
see the problem is there's a trade-off
between
sort of the do the right thing thing for
these data sets
and they specify everything we're
specifying everything is immensely
complicated
and we're trying to you know walk a
middle line between those two
and the question is a lighted form
format i agree
that that's a potential thing that we
could parametrize
although what we have right now is not
terrible and there are a lot of
different cases
well so what are you asking but in terms
of the front end i mean what
what do you want to have happen i mean
this hasn't this hasn't there's first
i've heard about this
issue so what i wanted to have happen
was it to be fixed but
i you know it's out of my hands and i've
been after
john to do something and it just hasn't
happened
so okay well if you want to send mail
that includes all the relevant people
then maybe we can surface what the issue
is can you describe what the front-end
issue
actually is yeah well it was so
you have the cells and the data set in
order to edit one you click in the cell
but that cell behind the scenes contains
an input field
which doesn't fill the entire cell if
you don't click in the input field you
don't get an insertion point
so there needs to be an item size arrow
full
for input fields it makes them expand
to the enclosing grid cell
okay has any work been done on that
i i don't believe so
okay who would like to take charge of
who's who's project managing here
pretty brady's here i can i can chase
this down
there's a there's a jira issue for it i
can send you the jira issue
yes and there's also there's also a
blocker in the
cloud the grid doesn't handle his
content sizes properly
uh jan was looking into that in the last
couple days he would
was not able to fix it yet i gave him a
heads up that
that maybe editing was not going to go
into 12.3 i don't know if he stopped
working that or not
well i mean it's uh you know 1.58 is
going out on wednesday
right so this will be in 1.58.2
and um i don't know when that closes
i'll i'll i'll sort this out okay
um
okay okay i would it would be nice to
have anything i'd love to see editing i
mean
not not having ever used it so so i just
get to
click on one of these things and i can
edit it is that correct yeah
in place you just click it you edit it
you okay
so then then i can take this thing which
is an output cell
and i edit it does it break its its
connection to the input cell
it doesn't copy down but it breaks its
connection to the input cell yeah just
like
editing anything else okay and then so i
can press shift enter on that thing
is that correct yeah what the hell did
that do
what did that do why did that all go
bold
because it turned into an input an input
oh boy oh
i i think it's kind of ugly but i think
it's correct too
no no no no it's very ugly right
but this means any bold non-bold
distinction is blown up by one of these
things turning into input
right yeah
well that's an issue i mean it's not
isn't that the case for anything though
it is but we don't use bold versus
non-bold that there is
almost nothing that is used as input
has bold versus non-bold distinctions in
it
so what is that because we're not
specifying font weight goes to normal or
something right
if you encase it in a scoped font style
wouldn't that protect from the bold
if we want that i mean it's not it's not
totally obvious but i mean
the thing is what's a precedent for
something
that is a essentially a display form
like this
well what about graphics would you want
all the tick
labels to be bold it's a little
different but
you know you're right you're right it's
silly right
i mean in the case of a grid for example
if i make a grid
and then i make and i edit this
did that go bold yeah yes it's semibolt
because it's source and again
if this font was source it'd be less you
know
apparent it'd look better but it still
you know you
you basically flatten out the bold
non-bold which isn't great
so you mean this would have flattened
the bolt and on bolt if i'd had a bolt
there it would have just flattened it
i think so yeah but i think that's
that's the case i mean if i make that
bold
the hell did that do oh i see that was
that that is bold now and now your four
is bolder than your two
yeah okay well okay so so i don't think
it's
we need to think this through i i
suspect it's not right for it to go bold
for the same reason as jeremy points out
that isn't right for
for you know labels and graphics to go
bold
see what i'm saying chris right yep
um but presumably it should not
be unchanged either right
i agree although graphics would be
unchanged wouldn't it how would you know
that a graphic is being used as input
see what i'm asking yeah
okay so now let me just use that as
input yeah there's no difference
well yeah maybe that's better yeah
i don't i think it doesn't doesn't want
to just muddy the thing up with
bold all over the place that doesn't
make sense i mean it's sort of similar
to what happens with the
large output suppression
which is what it
you know everything gets bolded
right um
i think i agree it should not change
okay all right we should wrap this up i
think we've made very good progress here
sorry it was a little turbulent there
um a couple more comments i'm looking at
here
there's a question from dongs about
themed notebooks will will the tables
theme against
they will when you reevaluate them they
will not change their theming
dynamically that correct guys
correct
um
uh ethan is saying you can't set a hint
click or set autocomplete in the cloud
for input fields that's i didn't know
that
brady that's another thing you could
chase with the on
um okay if there's nothing else
this is great but i think we we do need
to get an update on this real soon
yeah um and this is very nice stuff
um even nicer when we have editing and
hopefully that will squeak
in to this version okay
all right see y'all soon thank you
thanks to folks on the live stream lots
of
very useful comments um
okay there's also image size and return
key i've never worked for input field
and cloud
notebooks sounding like input field and
cloud notebooks is
quite impoverished here let's try and
give it some some life yeah
um okay all right see you guys soon
thanks